Here's the new way to do copywriting in
2026.
Stop chasing clients. Instead, make
yourself your very first and forever
client. This is exactly how you do it.
You need an audience, an email list, and
something to sell them. You can build an
audience on any social media platform
nowadays. You can go on Substack, you
can go on Twitter, you can go on
YouTube, just like you are right now.
You can create videos and write content
around a very specific niche where you
help a very specific person solve a very
specific problem, okay? Once you start
building an audience, you move those
people to an email list by giving them
something for free in exchange for their
email address. That's called a lead
magnet. Once they're on your email list,
email them every day and make them an
offer to buy something from you, a
course, a community, coaching, something
where you can help them solve another
problem. This scales infinitely because
the internet scales infinitely and you
start dealing with customers instead of
clients. And you start building a stable
business as a creator who does copy
instead of a copywriter who begs for
clients. Try this and I guarantee you'll
be happier. And if you missed it,